when causing was sacked yesterday Jeremy
Hunt a former Richie sunax supporter was
not the replacement that many expected
list trust to appoint but speaking
yesterday the Prime Minister insisted
that Hunter she called one of the most
experienced and widely respected
government ministers was the right man
to tackle one of the toughest entries of
any new chancellor has faced in decades
so I am joined now from Westminster by
the chancellor Jeremy Hunt very good
morning to you thanks so much for
talking to us here this morning good
morning Anna now the the government
under Liz truss has lost the confidence
of the markets hasn't it it's seen
people's mortgages costs shoot up
it's been forced into major u-turns on
key economic policy and has had to sack
the chancellor after a fewer than 40
days in the job why do you want to work
with this government
because I want to do the right thing for
the British people it's a big honor to
do the job that I've been asked to do by
the Prime Minister but I want to be
honest with people we have some very
difficult decisions ahead the last few
weeks have been very tough but the
context of course is coming out of a
pandemic and a cost of living crisis and
the thing that people want the markets
want the country needs now is stability
no chance look and control the markets
but what I can do is show that we can
pay for our tax and spending plans
and that is going to need some very
difficult decisions on both spending and
tax but that is what I must do now so
that people who are worried about their
mortgage costs going up people are
worried about how they're going to get
through winter with the cost of living
crisis people in the NHS who are worried
about the pressures they're facing can
be reassured that the fundamental
stability that they they need from the
government they expect the government to
provide is there
you say you want to restore stability
but the the party and the country
actually reputation for economic
competence has been Trashed by the mini
budget hasn't it I mean quasi quaten has
paid the price for that by losing his
job but can you rebuild that reputation
when the architect of those proposals in
the mini budget is still in her job Liz
truss is still prime minister
well she's been prime minister for less
than five weeks um what I would say
about the mini budget is the chaos that
it's caused well let's talk about the
mini budget
um the most important element of it was
the energy price guarantee People's
Energy bills were having for six and a
half thousand pounds this will keep the
average one down at two and a half
thousand pounds that's very important to
families up and down the country that's
staying but there were mistakes it was a
mistake when we're going to be asking
for difficult decisions across the board
on tax and spending to cut the rate of
tax paid by the very wealthiest it was a
mistake to fly blind and to uh to do
these forecasts without giving people
the confidence of the office for Budget
responsibility saying that the sums add
up and the prime ministers recognize
that that's why I'm here and what we
need now is for me to show Parliament
and the markets that we can make our tax
and spending plans add up that's what
I'm going to do and I want to say this
Anna if I may we will have some very
difficult decisions ahead spending will
not rise by as much as people would like
and all government departments are going
to have to find more efficiencies than
they were planning to and some taxes
will not be cut as quickly as people
want some taxes will go up so it's going
to be difficult but as we take those
difficult decisions
my priority are values as a government
will be to protect families businesses
who are going through a very challenging
time we'll be thinking about the most
vulnerable people this is a
compassionate conservative government
and the other thing is that we still
maintain total fundamental confidence in
the potential of the British economy we
have enormous amount we can do with a
fifth or sixth largest economy in the
world but we've remained a strong
economy because at difficult moments
like this we've been prepared to take
tough decisions and that's I'm afraid
what we're going to have to do okay and
I'm going to explore those tough
decisions what it means for spending in
a moment but first of all I want to get
a sense of the direction that you're
heading in because the mini budget has
had its heart ripped out of it hasn't it
after these reversals on corporation tax
and the 45p tax rate many are saying
that trust economics is dead so what is
next from you in terms of policy how
much of a departure will there be from
Liz truss and quati quattange's vision
well
um as I said some of the things were
mistakes but the fundamental strategy
behind it all which is that we have to
solve the growth Paradox if we want
well-funded Public Services like the NHS
and to keep taxes low and falling then
we have to increase our growth rate that
is absolutely right and I also would
like to be able to cut corporation tax I
want us to have the most competitive
business taxes because that's the way
that we'll help to grow the economy but
the way we did it didn't give people
confidence that's what we have to change
and that's my job in the next couple of
weeks with the the statement that will
be coming out on the 31st of October
can the markets wait that long they're
clearly not satisfied at the moment they
think that the sums don't add up they no
doubt will want to see more details and
what will they be will that mean more
reversals on the mini budget will there
be more u-turns well I'm being very
straightforward we're going to have to
take some very tough decisions on both
spending and tax as I say spending will
not go up as much as people want and
there'll be more efficiencies to find
and we won't have uh the speed of tax
cuts we're hoping for and some taxes
will have to go up that's the reality of
the very challenging situation we face
but remember Anna we've only heard one
part of the equation we're hearing you
now about some of the difficult
decisions but also there's enormous
potential for growth with some of the
other policies that we'll be announcing
in the next few months and when you see
the package as a whole what you will see
is a vote of confidence in the British
economy this country that has four of
the world's top 10 universities as one
of the world two biggest Financial
Centers Europe's biggest technology
sector we have a huge amount going for
us but we have to do that by taking
difficult decisions at moments like this
and that's what I'll be doing
more efficiencies to find are we talking
austerity level Cuts again
I don't think we're talking about
austerity in the way we had it in 2010
when I was also in the cabinet but we
are talking about very difficult
decisions in budgets where there is
already a great deal of pressure so
which budgets which departments are
likely to be targeted well I'm going to
ask all departments to find more
efficiencies than they were planning to
find remember I ran the biggest spending
department
for many years so I know how just how
difficult it is to find those
efficiencies but we're all going to have
to play our part across the board but I
do want to reassure people my priority
as we take these decisions and indeed
the government's priority will be to
help families and businesses that are
struggling
and to demonstrate that as a country
when we go through difficult times we
understand the pressures facing the most
vulnerable people
can guarantee will maintain their
funding will the NHS still get all the
funding that was promised when the
Health and Social care Living was
announced for example
well the government's already made that
commitment and we fully I think I
understand more than most the pressures
in the NHS and indeed the social care
system but I'm not going to make any
specific commitments about specific
departments now or indeed on the tax
side about specific taxes because we
have to look at these things in the
round and we have to make sure as we
take these very difficult decisions
we're honest with people about
situation we Face the big International
challenges we're going to take those
difficult decisions but we are going to
remember that as a country we are a
decent country we are a kind country and
we will remember the needs of the most
vulnerable people as we take those
decisions
well there's truss as prime minister
ever be able to inspire the confidence
of the markets when her Central ideology
has been such a disaster
well I think our Central ideology has
been that we've got to get growth into
the economy I think she's the first to
accept in fact the reason I'm sitting
here
uh that the way that she and the former
Chancellor went about it didn't work and
that's why we're doing it a different
way but the objective to get growth into
the economy so that we can fund the
Public Services like the NHS that we all
need so much that is absolutely Central
to me and every single one of my
conservative colleagues and that we are
going to go about with redoubled effort
because it's so important it's it's
important in the good times but it's
very important in tough times like the
times we face right now it's interesting
you talk about your conservative
colleagues I mean there's still turmoil
in the markets even after her
announcements yesterday Sterling and the
bond markets suffered if the markets
don't bring her down isn't there a high
chance that Tory MPS will
well what the country wants now is
stability
um you know as you mentioned in your
introduction I didn't vote for Liz truss
but I'm supporting her because I agree
with her fundamental plans for this
country which is to get us back growing
so we can afford all the things that we
really want to be successful but also to
be a compassionate Society to have a
really good public services and I think
that's what the country wants they want
a conservative party that is United
behind our leader and is trying to do
the very best thing for the country and
I think actions speak louder than words
that's what we're going to do heads down
over the next few weeks and months
okay Jeremy Hunt the new Chancellor
lyrics checker on your first full day in
the new job thanks very much indeed for
your time thank you
so plenty to pick over there with our
political correspondent Rob Powell who's
been listening in there in our
Westminster Studio too so Rob what did
we learn from the new Chancellor of the
direction of travel uh with him in the
job I think that was something of a cold
hard reality check from the new
Chancellor uh there Anna uh Jeremy Hunt
making quite clear that his primary
purpose in the treasury right now is to
restore economic credibility to the UK
restore economic stability
um as well he said that essentially his
job now was to show how the government
can pay for its tax and spending plans
and he uh made no bones about the fact
that this would be difficult that there
would be some very tough decisions he
said that departments would have to find
efficiency savings essentially public
spending would not rise as expecting
that departments would have to cut back
their budget you pressed him on whether
that would mean the NHS got all their
money he said that was or already a
commitment that was made but didn't make
any specific commitments that raises so
many issues around whether the NHS does
get the money it was expecting around
whether the ministry of defense gets the
increased funding that it was promised
by Liz trust during the leadership
campaign and follow on following on from
that there are the political
consequences of how do the various
secretaries of State react to the fact
that they are being told to trim their
budgets now also on the issue of tax as
well we clearly know that corporation
tax will now be going up Jeremy Hunt I
thought hinted that potentially there
could be more measures to come on tax
when he said that some taxes won't be
cut as quickly as some may want does
that mean further u-turns on things like
the cut to the basic rate of income tax
coming down to 19 pence in April next
year he also said that some taxes would
rise clearly a reference to corporation
tax there as well but I think that was
quite a sobering analysis of the
position we are are in and quite a
sobering
judgment if you like appraisal of the
impact of the last few weeks and of the
job that Jeremy Hunt now has ahead of
him
and and of course our viewers will be
watching closely but so too will Tory
MPS and the markets
yeah and I I think obviously it's two
two probably too early to say with
certainty but I think there will be a
degree of reassurance that is given by
that interview because what was
emphasized more than anything it was
clearly the message that Jeremy Hunt
went out there to put out there was
about restoring stability and
credibility and once again
um saying that the UK should be a
country that essentially shows how it is
going to pay for its spending and for
its tax cuts he admitted that there were
mistakes that had been made over the
last few weeks he said that it was a
mistake to fly blind in the mini budget
that's a reference to not having the obr
forecast there not having that
independent scrutiny of the plans that
unsettled the market and went on to
unsettle so many MPS he said it was a
mistake to go for the 45 Pence
um cut as well so admitting really that
key planks of the trust agenda for the
last few weeks key planks of the
government that he has just joined were
not in the right place over the last few
weeks and essentially saying his job in
the treasury now is to try and put out
some of those fires that have been
started by his cabinet colleagues and by
his predecessor a few weeks ago and try
and restore some semblance of
credibility and stability to the UK
um economy so
um so sobering I think is the word I'd
use about that interview but also
probably humbling given that he is
essentially Jeremy Hunters essentially
said his job now is to repair some of
the Damage Done in the last month
yeah he kept talking about stability
didn't he I'm sure that's something that
he will continue to talk about
um over the next few days fascinating to
see what the reaction will be but Rob
thanks very much indeed for that very
quick take on our interview with the new
Chancellor of the exchecker Jeremy Hunt